did you read the times this morning new
york time
yeah i saw i saw the times this morning
at one point on friday
amazon.com's total stock market value
surged past
30 billion dollars making it worth more
than a major industrial
company like texaco
that didn't blow your mind when you read
it well i think if you're asking for
sort of an emotional
response i think it's it's it's very
humbling
and it creates a sense of responsibility
according to
my calculations you yourself are worth
somewhere
in the vicinity of nine or ten billion
dollars today
i only say that because i've got a
follow-up question okay what's with the
honda
this is a perfectly good car i love bob
simon
welcome back to cbs this morning that
was amazon's jeff bezos talking to the
late 60 minutes correspondent
bob simon back in 1999 more than two
decades
later amazon's market value now exceeds
1.6 trillion dollars and forbes says
bezos is the world's richest man
with a net worth of nearly 200 billion
dollars
yesterday amazon announced he is
stepping down as its ceo
in the company's earnings report bezos
will be replaced by amazon's web
services chief
andy jassy i think he's planning a
cross-country trip in the honda
now
he consults me with nothing about his
business decisions but i was
really surprised to get that news
yesterday but it sounds very good
there's a lot of other
projects you know blue origin the the
space project space venture he's got and
he's very involved with that and
so i you know i don't got a game plan
he's not going off to somebody
so you know he's got a bright future
ahead of him i think he'll figure it out
i can't wait to see what it is a high
potential individual